Eh, nosotros lo que venimos a denunciar es le
la situación totalmente anómala
que se está dando dentro del cabildo de Gran Canaria.
O sea, eh, a pesar de las repetidas sentencias que están
um confirmando los nombramientos
nulos de directores generales nombrados a dedo
se sigue con esta tónica
de forma generalizada y recurrente,
estando por encima de la legalidad.
Es más, en diciembre de 2 023,
ya con el director de comunicación actual,
el señor Anuar Marrero,
eh, se les ha vuelto a decir que el nombramiento es nulo
y esta persona continúa trabajando.
Esto ha pasado
con proponer algunos ejemplos,
por ejemplo con el señor gerau lobo,
con eh Francisco bayori,
con Jorge Ramos y 1 largo etc. eh,
Jorge Ramos continúa también aquí trabajando.
Nosotros vamos a denunciar en este,
en este pleno,
que qué van a hacer,
que si van a seguir estando por encima de la legalidad
y que si si van a seguir teniendo este cabildo,
esta corporación insular con dinero público,
su propia e t t particular
para seguir manteniendo
a las personas que ellos quieren
colocar esta forma de trabajo,
esta forma de contratación,
totalmente fuera de la legalidad
y que saben que es así,
como mínimo desde 2020 se está produciendo.
Pero esto um viene de mucho más atrás.
Yo no concibo que 1 administración pública
piense que está por encima de las normas,
de las leyes y de las sentencias judiciales